Transcriber:
Today, I'm going to talk about
a shameful topic.
This has happened to many of us,
and it's embarrassing,
but if we don't talk about it,
nothing will ever change.
It's about being hacked.
Some of us have clicked on a phishing link
and downloaded a computer virus.
Some of us have had our identities stolen.
And those of us
who are software developers
might have written insecure code
with security bugs in it
without realizing it.
As a cybersecurity expert,
I have worked with countless companies
on improving their cybersecurity.
Cybersecurity experts like me
have advised companies
on good cybersecurity practices,
monitoring tools
and proper user behaviors.
But I actually see a much bigger problem
that no tool can fix:
the shame associated with
the mistakes that we make.
We like to think of ourselves
as competent and tech savvy,
and when we make these mistakes
that can have a really bad impact
on us and our companies --
anything from a simple annoyance,
to taking a lot of time to fix,
to costing us and our employers
a lot of money.
Despite billions of dollars
that companies spend on cybersecurity,
practitioners like me see the same
problems over and over again.
Let me give you some examples.
The 2015 hack of Ukrainian utilities
that disconnected power
for 225,000 customers
and took months to restore
back to full operations
started with a phishing link.
By the way, 225,000 customers
is a lot more 225,000 people.
Customers can be anything
from an apartment building
to an industrial facility
to a shopping mall.
The 2017 data breach of Equifax
that exposed personally
identifiable information
of 140 million people
and may ultimately cost Equifax something
on the order of 1.4 billion dollars:
that was caused by an exploitation
of a well-known vulnerability
in the company's customer
consumer complaint portal.
Fundamentally, this is about
technology and innovation.
Innovation is good;
it makes our lives better.
Most of the modern cars we drive today
are fundamentally computers on wheels.
They tell us where to go to avoid traffic,
when to take them in for maintenance
and then give us all kinds of
modern-day conveniences.
Many people use connected
medical devices like pacemakers
and glucose monitors with insulin pumps.
These devices make
these people's lives better
and sometimes even extend their lives.
But anything that can be interconnected
can be hacked when it's connected.
Did you know that the former
US Vice President Dick Cheney
kept his pacemaker disconnected from Wi-Fi
before he received a heart transplant?
I will let you figure out why.
In a digitally interconnected world,
cyber risks are literally everywhere.
For years, my colleagues and I
have been talking about
this elusive notion
of cybersecurity culture.
Cybersecurity culture is when
everybody in the organization
believes that cybersecurity is their job,
knows what to do and what not to do
and does the right thing.
Unfortunately, I can't tell you
which companies do this well,
because by doing so, I would put
a juicy target on their backs
for ambitious attackers.
But what I can do is make
cybersecurity less mysterious,
bring it out into the open
and talk about it.
There should be no mystery or secrecy
within an organization.
When something is invisible
and it's working,
we don't know that it's there
until it's not there.
Kind of like toilet paper.
When the COVID-19 pandemic began,
what has been there all of a sudden
became super important
because we couldn't find it anywhere.
Cybersecurity is just like that:
when it's working, we don't know,
and we don't care.
But when it's not working,
it can be really, really bad.
Toilet paper is pretty straightforward.
Cybersecurity is mysterious and complex.
And I actually think it starts
with the notion of psychological safety.
This notion was popularized
by an organizational behavior scientist,
Amy Edmondson.
Amy studied behavior of medical teams
in high-stakes situations like hospitals,
where mistakes could be fatal.
And she found out
that nurses were not comfortable
bringing up suggestions to the doctors
because of the fear
of questioning authority.
Amy helped improve medical teams
to make nurses more comfortable
bringing up suggestions to the doctors
for patient treatment
without the fear of being
scolded or demeaned.
For that to happen, doctors needed
to listen and be receptive --
without judging.
Psychological safety is when everybody
is comfortable speaking up
and pointing things out.
I want cybersecurity to be the same.
And I want cybersecurity practitioners
to be comfortable bringing suggestions up
to senior executives
or software developers,
without being dismissed as those people
who continue to talk about
horrors and errors,
and say no.
Not doing so is really hard
for the individuals who are responsible
for the creation of digital products
because fundamentally, it's about
their pride and joy in their creations.
I once tried talking to a senior
software development executive
about the need to do better security.
You know what he said?
"Are you telling me
we're developing insecure code?"
In other words, what he heard
was, "Your baby is ugly."
What if instead of focusing on
what not to do,
we focused on what to do?
Like, how do we develop better software
and protect our customer
information at the same time?
Or how do we make sure
that our organization is able to operate
in crisis, under attack
or in an emergency?
And what if we reward good things that
people do in cybersecurity in some way
and encourage them to do so,
like reporting security incidents,
reporting potential phishing emails,
or finding and fixing
software security bugs
in the software that they develop?
And what if we tied these good security
actions to performance evaluations
to make it really matter?
I would love for us to communicate
these good cybersecurity things
and encourage them in some sort of
company-wide communications
like newsletters, blogs,
websites, microsites --
whatever we use to communicate
to our organization.
What if a company announced a competition
for who finds the most security bugs
and fixes them in a two-week
development sprint
and then announces the winner
of the competition for the quarter
at a large company virtual town hall,
and then rewards these people,
these winners, with something meaningful,
like a week's vacation or a bonus.
Others will see
the celebration and recognition,
and they'll want to do the same.
In the energy industry,
there is a really strong
culture of safety.
People care about this culture,
are proud of it,
and there is a collective
reinforcement of this culture
to make sure that nobody gets hurt.
One of the ways they exhibit and keep
this safety conscious culture going
is by counting and visibly displaying days
since the last safety incident.
And then everybody works really hard
not to have that count go back to zero
because that means
that somebody did get hurt.
Cybersecurity is the same as safety.
What if we all agree
to keep that count of days
since the last cybersecurity incident
going on forever
and then work really hard
not to have it reset to zero?
And then certain things are a no-no,
and we need to clearly communicate
to our organizations what they are
in an easily digestible
and maybe even fun way,
like gamification or simulations,
to make sure that people
can remember this.
And if somebody does something
they're not supposed to do,
they should face some sort
of consequences.
So, for example, if an employee buys
equipment on Amazon or eBay
or uses personal Dropbox
for their company business,
then they should face
some sort of consequences.
And when this happens, executives
should get the same treatment
as regular employees,
because if they don't,
then people won't believe that it's real
and will go back to their old behaviors.
It's OK to talk about mistakes,
but just like a teenager who violates
the rules tells us about it,
we appreciate that they told us about it,
but there should still be
some sort of consequences.
Cybersecurity is a journey.
It's not a destination,
and we need to keep working on it.
I would love for us to celebrate
cybersecurity people
like the heroes that they are.
If we think about it,
they are firefighters,
emergency room doctors and nurses,
law enforcement, risk executives
and business strategists
all in the same persona.
And they help us protect our modern life
that we like so much.
They protect our identities,
our inventions, our intellectual property,
our electric grid, medical devices,
connected cars and myriad other things.
And I'd like to be on that team.
So let's agree that this thing
is with us to stay,
let's create a safe environment
to learn from our mistakes,
and let's commit to making things better.
Thank you.